after the United States defeated Spain
in the late 19th century it took most of
its remaining Imperial possessions it
annexed Guam and Puerto Rico and turned
the Philippines into a protectorate yet
Cuba Central to why the war started in
the first place was left to become
independent despite some calls in the
United States for its annexation and
given that the USA took the rest of
Spain's colonies for its own Why didn't
it also Annex Cuba so as of 1898 Cubans
had been fighting on and off for decades
to win their independence from Spain
when another Rebellion began in Earnest
the Spanish response was seen as quite
harsh in America this led to many there
calling for intervention to save the
Cuban people which was backed by
American Business who did a lot of trade
with Cuba and also when the USS Maine
was in Havana Harbor it exploded most
Americans blamed Spain Spain claimed
that it was an accident but the truth
didn't really matter it was time for war
to pretty bluntly the United States
crushed Spain and both then signed the
Treaty of Paris they saw Spain give up
the Philippines Guam Puerto Rico and
Cuba guaman Puerto Rico were immediately
taken by the United States and the
Philippines was a slightly more
controversial issue this was because its
Rebels had hoped that the United States
would help them become a sovereign
independent state but fun fact no
instead the US opted to keep the
Philippines a much like Spain before it
brutally crushed any rebellions there so
why was Cuba different why didn't the
U.S take it like close by Puerto Rico
well one of the main reasons that Cuba
isn't now a state is a man called Henry
teller teleput forward the Teller
Amendment which meant that the US
government was forbidden from annexing
Cuba and this was backed by a broad
Coalition of U.S politicians some didn't
want the agricultural competition that
Cuban sugar plantations would bring
others just wanted to see the United
States liberate Cuba and welcome it as a
sovereign sister Republic whereas some
backers just didn't want more hispanical
black people in the United States now
whilst of course this was a major
roadblock it didn't mean that annexation
was forever off the table after Spain's
defeat the U.S occupied the island and
there was no strict timetable on when
they had to leave some in the government
thus saw this as an opportunity to
either take the islands after a long
wait or like the Philippines set up a
protectorate well in 1901 a new
president took office president Theodore
Roosevelt II as many of you will know
fought in Cuba during the war he had
strong personal belief that Cuba should
be independent and that it could be
trusted to set up a democratic
government there was of course
opposition by some in Congress to the
United States just simply leaving Cuba
without any gains and thus came the
Platt Amendment this pleased The
anti-annexation Crowd by leaving Cuba as
a nominally independent state whilst
also forcing the Cubans to give near
complete control of their economy to the
United States and in return for American
troops leaving Cuba it had to agree to
some punishing demands including never
making friends with any enemy of the USA
seeding some land here in Guantanamo Bay
to make room for an American Naval base
and allowing the U.S to intervene
militarily if its interests were ever
threatened this essentially made Cuba a
puppet state without formally making it
a puppet state the new Cuban government
agreed because what else could it do and
Cuba became fully independent without
occupation in 1903 a rebellion against
pro-american governments or U.S troops
return a few years later but there was
no real talk of annexation this was
because the United States had gained
most of the advantages of annexation
without any of the costs a template
which would be repeated in the following
decades by Future U.S governments in
Central America I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons James
bizonette Kelly moneymaker course show
wolf katoitska Adams daughter Jerry
lamdin Jordan Longley Alex Schwinn
Marcus arsner why in hockey Spencer
Lightfoot Marvin cassow Captain side dog
the mcgwapa Miss izet Winston caywood
community Wiggly Gustav Swan Aaron the
white Daniel tobian Anthony Beckett
Maggie Paskowski she went in spinning
three plates words about books podcast
Coppertone and Charles the first